[Music]
on this thursday night a day to honor
those lost and reflect on a terrible
legacy
[Music]
how the first national day for a truth
and reconciliation was marked true
reconciliation is about learning
sharing
and growing
where is the prime minister the answer
igniting anger as he's judged on his
actions and not his words
pressure on the pope renewed calls for
an apology and for the catholic church
to release the records on canada's
residential schools
and the story of the first person to
wear an orange shirt by you wearing
orange and learning about what happened
to us it's like a little bit of justice
the woman who inspired what's become the
day for truth and reconciliation
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
on this first national day for truth and
reconciliation ceremonies and events
have taken place across this country
this national day has been years in the
making until recently much of the
country was unaware of the history of
indian residential schools and their
long-lasting legacy the discovery of
unmarked graves of children was a
horrifying wake-up call today is about
honoring them the survivors their
families and communities canada's new
governor general mary mae simon is the
first indigenous person in that role her
message today is that we all must make
reconciliation a way of life that it
requires effort every day it has no end
date or finish line
as we strive to resolve the tensions of
the past with the promise of the future
we can stand together and move forward
with grace and humility
[Music]
in ottawa hundreds took part in a
ceremony on parliament hill canadians
are being called upon to own their own
truth when it comes to this country's
history and treatment of indigenous
people
downtown winnipeg was transformed into a
sea of orange as more than a thousand
people marched to the manitoba
legislature the color orange symbolizing
and honoring thousands of indigenous
children forcibly taken from their homes
and sent to residential schools and in
kamloops where the unmarked graves of
215 children were discovered this summer
the search continues as do the calls for
action nithu garcia is in kamloops
tonight nathan
donna a powerful show of support in
person behind me here with a drumming
circle and around the world we're
hearing international support has
crashed the tacoma loops to schwetmick
website where these events behind me are
being live streamed before they began
cook p also known as chief roseanne
kasmir provided an update saying that
more ground penetrating radar work has
been done in recent weeks and artifacts
that were recovered are now being
analyzed she believes that more unmarked
burial sites will be found as only two
of nearly 160 acres so far has been
surveyed we are at the tacoma
mcpow wow arbor an open air structure
which is just steps away from the former
kamloops indian residential school where
despite the efforts to eradicate their
culture the focus here today is on
reclaiming traditions and sharing them
with the world this includes as you can
hear singing
traditional honor songs ceremonial
drumming and with proof of vaccination
being checked at the entrance there are
hundreds of people here despite the
pandemic rain and wind also in
attendance is assembly of first nations
national chief roseanne archibald who
says she won't call them schools anymore
instead referring to them as
institutions of assimilation and
genocide cook p roseanne kasmir renewed
calls for politicians and the church to
release school attendance records so
they can work to reunite families with
lost loved ones but donna for some of
the survivors we spoke to sitting steps
away from their former residential
school they say this day is about their
grandchildren and a brighter future for
them starts with the truths about their
trauma being believed with every
canadian embracing our collective
history here's more from one of the
survivors we spoke to
we have to give our children and our
grandchildren every opportunity
that's available to them
and by
being able to
[Music]
showcase
our
songs and our dances here
is a door opener
for our people in this community because
it was
lost for a long time
nathu we learned today the prime
minister has flown to british columbia
and is spending some time in tofino with
family how has that news been received
by people there in kamloops
well donna there is disappointment over
prime minister justin trudeau's absence
and that turned into shock when it was
confirmed that the prime minister is
vacationing with family in tofino as we
speak to kamloops to schweitman cook p
roseanne kasmir told me she found it
upsetting that he would make plans to
vacation in the province where he's now
received two quote heartfelt invitations
to come connect with the community here
behind me here's more of what she had to
say
i am truly saddened that he was not able
to join us today i did hold out on hope
that maybe that he would be here
we have sent him two invitations
now donna in a global news interview
during the election campaign trudeau did
say that he would come to kamloops when
his quote right and appropriate to do so
he has yet to visit this community since
that announcement of the unmarked burial
sites in late may and the chief here
says she's holding on to hope that he
will come sooner rather than later back
to you all right neethu garcia in
kamloops bc tonight thanks canada's
conference of catholic bishops has
apologized but the chief of the tekam
loops to sequel first nation says it
rings hollow as long as the church
continues to withhold records of the
children who died
if this apology is truly a commitment
then tacomas deschawetmic insists
on the complete and full production of
all relevant documents and records in a
manner and form that is useful and
accessible to indian residential school
survivors
to help identify those missing and those
unmarked graves and repatriating
those lost
catholic bishops have promised millions
of dollars to support indigenous
reconciliation robin gill talks to
people living with the terrible legacy
of residential schools about what that
and an apology means to them
seashell indian residential school
operated until 1975 on what is
considered british columbia's sunshine
coast
gertie pierre has nothing but dark
memories from the time she walked
through those doors at the age of five
she suffered years of abuse at the hands
of the nuns and priests when you know i
got out of that school i was such an
angry
angry young girl now 75 years old she's
had time to heal i
forgave
you know the brothers sisters the nuns
and the priests but she doesn't accept
the recent apology from canada's bishops
she wants to hear from the top of the
catholic church it should come from the
higher up over the next five years
canada's catholic churches will
fundraise 30 million dollars the money
will be put toward indigenous
reconciliation projects including
counseling cindy blackstock has long
been an advocate for children who were
lost in the residential school system
she believes these gestures are hollow
it's good that they put out the words
but as the elder said integrity is when
words have meaning and the trc call to
action is for the pope to come to canada
and to accept responsibility for the
church's role in residential schools the
commission the truth and reconciliation
commission also known as the trc spent
years collecting stories from survivors
sent to boarding schools which were
primarily institutions to break their
link to their language to their culture
to their families this is well over 100
years of genocidal policies
that were imposed literally generations
of indigenous
children were brought into to
residential schools gertie pierre
considers herself catholic but her
indigenous spirituality plays just as
big a role
now she waits to see what the church
does next i'm not their judge you know
the
great spirit is the judge
the anger of her youth may be gone but
she can never forget the terrible
lessons she and so many other children
learned at residential schools robin
gill global news vancouver
in 2015 the trc clearly outlined 94
calls to action what the federal and
provincial governments need to do to
continue to uncover the truth and work
towards reconciliation prime minister
justin trudeau accepted that report and
pledged to implement all the calls to
action as david aiken reports he is
being judged on his actions not his
words
first came the harm for most of canada's
history the official policy of the
federal government towards indigenous
people
forced assimilation residential schools
a key tool for that job canada's
assimilation policies
that have attempted to extinguish us as
a people again make no mistake
this is genocide
then a change and an apology the
government of canada now recognizes
that it was wrong
to forcibly remove children from their
homes
and we apologize for having done this
that was followed by a commission to
find the truth and propose ways to
reconcile canada and the land's
indigenous peoples
and in 2015 a new prime minister and new
promises to fulfill all 94 calls to
action from the truth and reconciliation
commission it sets us squarely on the
path
to true reconciliation but ambition has
often exceeded action
too many priorities remain unfulfilled
we're no longer accepting hollow
apologies
concrete actions and change behaviors
are essential
on this first national day of truth and
reconciliation for example 32 first
nations communities are still without
clean water and just a handful of first
nations have the authority or the
resources to run their own education and
child welfare systems in the just
concluded federal election more promises
to do better this election mattered and
the choice canadians made to go even
further and even faster on the fight
against climate change to go even
stronger on reconciliation including on
economic reconciliation and creating
opportunities for indigenous peoples
across this country the prime minister
participated in a reconciliation
ceremony wednesday night here on
parliament hill his posted public
itinerary for today said he was to be in
ottawa for private meetings but in fact
global news discovered he was not in
ottawa but he and his family were on a
plane by 7 a.m eastern to travel to
tofino bc on vancouver island's west
coast so in that sense on this national
day of truth and reconciliation the
pmo's posted itinerary was not that
truthful now the pmo confirmed that
trudeau and his family will have a few
days of downtime in tofino but that
today the prime minister spent time on
the plane talking by phone to
residential school survivors donna okay
david aiken in ottawa thank you
we understand these stories and marking
this day may be difficult for many
people if you or someone you know needs
support you can call 1-866-925-4419
the indian residential schools crisis
line operates 24 hours a day
the struggle for young indigenous
canadians to find jobs coming up how
they're critical to rebuilding the
economy plus how should reconciliation
be defined and measured
in an exclusive interview with global
news the president of moderna says
delaying a second dose of its covet 19
vaccine up to four months has likely
extended protection so will canadians
need a booster carolyn jarvis is looking
into that tonight
when some canadian provinces decided to
delay second doses of the covet 19
vaccine it caused a stir would going off
label change the effectiveness of the
vaccine
now as the delta variant rages around
the world the president of moderna
stephen hogue says canadians who waited
longer for a second dose of its vaccine
could be seeing longer protection as a
result i think in retrospect we will
probably say that time between the doses
extended the durability of the vaccine
moderna's clinical trial data where
people receive two doses 28 days apart
indicates antibodies start to decrease
after six months at around the one year
mark they started to see breakthrough
infections
and that really is the intersection of
this declining immunity
and an increasing force of infection
from delta and about one year in the
united states that causes us to say we
think a booster dose of the vaccine
we'll get that neutralizing immunity
back up where it was and nice and strong
and stop those breakthrough cases
moderna is now advocating for a booster
of half the original dose six months
after your second shot so is it
plausible because canadians took longer
to get the second dose they won't need a
booster as quickly as others i think
it's not only plausible i think it's
likely because the more recently you
were boosted with your second dose the
less likely you're going to need a third
dose booster dr danuda squaronski at the
bc center for disease control is
monitoring vaccine effectiveness in real
time and says the protection from two
doses of an mrna vaccine remains
terrific when you have a longer interval
between the first and the second dose
you generally get higher
vaccine
immune responses while swaronski says
there's no evidence supporting the need
for a booster for everyone at this point
hogue counters things could look very
different in a few months if you
received your second dose the in the
summer
six months from now it could become a
very bad moment because you'll see high
forces of infection and breakthroughs
come christmas time in canada things
could look very different
i think that's the concern that in
christmas things could look very
different carolyn jarvis global news
boston
i ahead why canada's indigenous
workforce is key to pandemic recovery
the pandemic has been especially
difficult for young indigenous people
looking for work they're canada's
fastest growing demographic and as ann
gaviola explains ensuring their
employment is key to economic recovery
[Music]
the first national day for truth and
reconciliation really hits home for
carissa men's my grandma is a
residential school survivor from
saskatchewan and she's still struggling
with it and there's generations of
trauma and it's real the pandemic has
turned her life upside down after a
decade working her way up in the
restaurant industry she lost her
livelihood for months slide it through
here
with the help of access an aboriginal
community career service based in
vancouver she's re-skilled and has just
been hired at an electrical contracting
company paving the way for a brighter
future i can save money and the goal
eventually
maybe not in vancouver right now but
it's to buy a house kovit took a big
toll on indigenous employment in the
summer of 2020 the jobless rate among
aboriginal workers soared to nearly 17
hitting indigenous youth in particular
more than one in four were out of work
and according to analysis by rbc the
unemployment rate for indigenous people
was five percent higher than the
national average in the five years
leading up to covid experts say there's
an opportunity to do better the fastest
growing part of the population is
indigenous youth
roughly we estimate 750 000 indigenous
youth who are coming into the labor
force into their prime the pandemic has
been a roller coaster for carvel
electric a metis-owned business in
alberta the family-run company laid off
half its staff in the summer of 2020
only to rebound and hire each one of
them back a few months later now they're
hiring and expanding the core value of
our company
is create opportunities for indigenous
people and that's been a core value of
our family
for years but for every story of triumph
there's a story of struggle the
indigenous business community is asking
the federal government to meet targets
for procurement from indigenous
companies and prioritize access to fast
reliable internet from coast to coast to
coast anne gaviola global news toronto
next the journey to reconciliation
[Music]
for most canadians the term
reconciliation is familiar yet difficult
to define tonight ross lord looks at how
some are walking the path towards it
it escaped
the lock on me
is sliding away there are terms most of
us have never heard words used by nova
scotia migmal long before hockey became
canada's most popular sport
discoveries even to the women who
created this hockey documentary cheryl
maloney and her sister april i think the
game of hockey is
is such an amazing integral part of
canada and canadians
and that if our children grow up knowing
the migma had this amazing role in
sharing this can you imagine what that
does for reconciliation history that was
unknown or forgotten like migma
craftsmen making hockey sticks in the
1800s sticks that were widely used in
the early days of the national hockey
league we had no clue when we started
this that it would become such an
amazing
story
and
to today reflect on that how that story
was lost to not just my family but to
canadians reclaiming pride through
history one way perhaps to accelerate
reconciliation these researchers from
the university of manitoba's social
justice laboratory are working to
develop a reconciliation barometer that
considers a wide range of indicators
understanding what's happened the
connection between the past and the
present
current uh you know inequalities
and
strengths within you know communities we
can get a better sense of you know where
are we doing well where are we not doing
well and where do we then need to focus
our efforts
they plan to complete their
reconciliation barometer later this year
after six years of planning back in nova
scotia cheryl maloney found another
point of pride her son chase posing with
this 1917 stick after they discovered it
was handmade by his
great-great-grandfather
alexander cope we're just trying to
acknowledge you know the roots of this
game and the role of the mi'kmaq people
and and i think that's something great
for canadians that we can celebrate
different methods for reconciling the
past and creating a future of equality
and fairness
ross lord global news schumann academy
nova scotia
that's global national i'm donna friesen
thanks for watching september 30th truth
and reconciliation day has long been
known as orange shirt day and it's worth
remembering who wore the first orange
shirt her name is phyllis webstad she's
54 now it's what happened to her when
she was six living on a reserve that's
never left her
lived with my grandmother
we didn't have electricity we didn't
have running water it was 1973.
the year she was sent to st joseph's
mission residential school just outside
williams lake bc
that day she wore a bright orange shirt
i remember it was an orange shiny color
but when i got to the mission
it was taken and i i never wore it again
and
i didn't understand why
and nothing was ever explained why
things were happening she talked about
that orange shirt when she testified
before the truth and reconciliation
commission in 2013. friendly and strange
and she's kept telling her story writing
books teaching a new generation the
truth about residential schools and
inspiring the orange shirt movement
the color orange has always reminded me
of that and how my feelings didn't
matter how no one cared and how i felt
like i was worth nothing she writes all
of us little children were crying and no
one cared
that sense of worthlessness of
insignificance is a legacy that spans
generations my grandmother attended for
10 years all of her 10 children
including my mother for 10 years and
myself for one she says since then she's
been on a healing journey and is helping
lead the country on that journey
her story is only one among many and
telling it has helped others open up and
tell theirs
websted says she didn't set out to do
this but that from the very beginning
the whole orange shirt movement has been
divinely guided the ancestors are behind
this whole movement
and that is what gives her the strength
to continue